nous vous en parlions en début de
semaine un policier tour on joue a été
condamné lundi par le tribunal de tours
pour avoir giflé un homme cet été lors
d'une intervention
cet après midi une vingtaine d'agents
des forces de l'ordre se sont réunis
devant le palais de justice on soutien à
leurs collègues
il trouve cette décision injuste paul
boyer les sirènes résonnent ce matin
devant le palais de justice
plusieurs dizaines de policiers se sont
donné rendez-vous pour protester contre
un verdict qui considèrent comme injuste
la plupart d'entre eux affichent un
soutien sans faille à leurs collègues
condamnés pour violences volontaires
on est désabusé dégoûté et qui aurait
aujourd'hui on a collé qui a été
sanctionné pour avoir mis une claque de
réanimation sur les bords de loire c
était donc une claque aujourd'hui
l'appui six mois avec sursis
il est suspendu un de 18 mois de
l'exercer contactez le procureur
grégoire du lin explique que justice a
été rendue c'est cet argument que
reprend le président du tribunal dans un
communiqué publié ce matin suite à la
manifestation
cette situation n'a pu être perçue que
comme une forme de pression sur les
magistrats en charge du dossier
il convient de rappeler que le procès du
policier en cause s'est déroulé au cours
d'une audience publique au cours de
laquelle des témoins ont été entendus et
la défense a pu s'exprimer
en démocratie la justice se rend dans
les prétoires et non dans les rues elle
doit pouvoir passer sereinement sans
pression d'où qu'elle vienne
cette colère ne concerne pas
exclusivement la sphère de leurs
collègues condamnés les syndicats
présents pointe du doigt un manque de
moyens et d'effectifs au sein des forces
de l'ordre
les difficultés des policiers sont
croissantes avec un sous-effectif de
plus en plus marquée des conditions de
travail et d'exercice de plus en plus
difficile et pour autant on a un
couperet permanent au dessus de la tête
une analyse quasiment à charge des
actions de police
et c'est ce qui pose problème autant au
service enquêteur au service de voie
publique
les faits qui remontent au mois de
juillet dernier s'inscrit plus
globalement dans un contexte de défiance
entre les citoyens et les forces de
l'ordre